two-year-old peter hardiman's got his
hands on the last chelsea shirt from the
club shop before it closed its doors
he's wearing a piece of football history
now the roman abramovich era is over
they closed the door behind us put the
signs up everything was really normal in
the shop um you wouldn't have thought
there was sanctions at all but obviously
and the doors are closed and that's it
the amount of money he invested he
really seems like he loves the club it
probably is all just a lie pumped out by
some media team of history i don't know
to make him look good
games will be allowed to continue
salaries will still be paid the uk
government sanctions have stopped
chelsea from selling merchandise and
even new tickets to matches and
lucrative sponsorship deals are in
jeopardy abramovic has owned chelsea for
19 years overseeing a reversal of the
club's fortunes with a massive injection
of cash
but moscow's invasion of ukraine has
focused the attention on his alleged
ties with vladimir putin putting the
oligarch on a collision course for the
british government
i think when you look at what is
happening in ukraine and you you look at
to the uh the casual rejection of every
norm of civilized behavior in in bombing
a a maternity hospital i think people in
this country can see that people
connected to the putin regime and need
to be sanctioned and that's what we're
doing the sanctions are immediate
including a freeze on all assets and a
travel ban
it's something abramovich appears to
have seen coming announcing the club was
up for sale last week and putting some
of his multi-million dollar portfolio of
london properties on the market
abramovic also has a stake in everest
steel headquartered in london with
operations in russia and ukraine
the british government said the company
had potentially been involved in
supplying steel to the russian military
in use in the production of tanks
after two weeks of fighting in ukraine
the net is finally starting to close
around some of those seen as
facilitators of vladimir putin and as
such the war in ukraine but the question
is whether this is two weeks too late to
prevent abramovich and other oligarchs
from simply shifting their money
elsewhere
abramovic also holds portuguese and
israeli passports and has spent a lot of
time in the uae
there are no shortage of places for him
to stash his billions
it's a similar story for the six other
oligarchs added to britain's sanctions
list
including alexey miller the head of
russian energy giant gazprom
igor sechin the owner of ross naft oil
company a metals magnet oleg deripaska
all members of putin's inner circle
it's being called the end of the roman
empire
sanctions aimed at stopping abramovic
and others making money in the uk
as for the club its future's uncertain
it needs a new well-heeled owner quickly
now the most prominent russian oligarch
in britain is no longer welcome
neve barker al jazeera london